Qual é o melhor suplemento paraa
reparação da parede intestinal? Sabe
quando você sente aquele desconforto
intestinal, aquela sensação de
estofamento ou até mesmo parece que tudo
que você come não cai bem? Pois é, pode
ser que a sua parede intestinal esteja
precisando de uma forcinha extra para se
recuperar. É exatamente sobre isso que
vamos conversar hoje. Quais são os
melhores suplementos para ajudar nesse
processo de reparação? Imagina comigo, o
seu intestino é como se fosse uma
muralha protetora, OK? uma barreira
super importante que separa o que está
dentro do intestino do resto do seu
corpo. Quando essa muralha está íntegra,
perfeita, ela deixa passar só o que é
bom, os nutrientes que você precisa. Mas
quando ela está danificada, aí meu
amigo, é como se tivesse uns buraquinhos
nessa parede e coisas que não deveriam
passar começam a vazar pro seu corpo. É
o que a gente chama de intestino
premiável ou em inglês o famoso lickut.
Agora vem cá. Você sabia que existe um
aminoácido que é praticamente o pedreiro
do seu intestino?
É a famosa glutamina, pessoal. Ela é um
tipo de material de construção preferido
das células intestinais, os chamados
interócitos. Quando se suplementa com
glutamina, é como se você estivesse
entregando tijolo e cimento pros seus
intestinos se reconstruírem. E olha que
bacana, ela não só ajuda a tapar os
buraquinhos da parede, como também tem
ação anti-inflamatória.
É especialmente útil quando você passou
por algum estresse intestinal, tipo
depois de tomar muito antiinflamatório,
fazer quimioterapia ou até depois de uma
cirurgia. Mas esa aí que tem mais coisa
nessa história. Você já ouviram falar do
butirato? Esse nome pode parecer
estranho, mas é um dos melhores amigos
do seu intestino. O butirato é um ácido
grásico cadeia curta que funciona como
combustível. pros colonóstitos, que são
as células do seu intestino grosso ou
colon, é como se fosse a gasolina
preferida deles, ok? E tem uns
suplementos bem legais, como a
tributirina ou coreiome, que entregam
esse butirato direitinho onde ele
precisa chegar. E o resultado?
Regeneração da mucosa, menos inflamação
e uma barreira intestinal mais forte. E
não para por aí, não. Lembra daquele
caldinho de osso que a sua vovó fazia
quando você estava dodói? Pois é, a
sabedoria popular tinha razão. O
colágeno presente nesse caldo é rico em
glicina e glutamina que ajudam demais na
reparação do revestimento intestinal.
Hoje em dia, você nem precisa ficar
horas fazendo o caldo. Você pode
simplesmente comprar o produto pronto, o
colágeno hidrolizado em pó. É
praticidade com eficiência, não é?
Agora, deixa te contar uma coisa que
muita gente não sabe. As fibras solúveis
são como se fossem um alimento preferido
das suas bactérias do bem. Quando você
consome fibras como a goma cásia ou
malto resistente, as bactérias boas do
seu intestino fazem uma festinha, elas
fermentam essas fibras e produzem,
adivinha o quê? Isso mesmo, butirato. É
a natureza trabalhando a seu favor e de
quebra ainda aumenta a produção de
mucoprotetor e melhora toda a
diversidade da sua microbiota. E por
falar em bactérias, os probióticos são
como se fosse os soldadinhos do bem que
você manda pro seu intestino. Cepas
específicas de lactobacilos e
bifidobactérium ajudam a equilibrar todo
o ecossistema intestinal. É
especialmente importante depois de tomar
antibiótico, que é como se fosse uma
bomba que mata tanto as bactérias ruins
quanto as boas. Os probióticos ajudam a
repovoar o seu intestino com os mocinhos
da história. Tem uma vitamina que é meio
coringa nessa história toda. Adivinha
qual é? A famosíssima vitamina D de
dado? Além de ser importante pros ossos,
ela tem um papel fundamental na
modulação do sistema imunointestinal. É
como se ela fosse a mediadora, ajudando
a acalmar a inflamação e melhorar a
mucosa intestinal. Muita gente tem
deficiência e nem sabe. E olha que
interessante, existe um composto chamado
zincarnosina, que é tipo um bandade pro
seu intestino. Ele tem efeito
cicatrizante, antiinflamatório direto na
mucosa. Tem também os nucleotídios, que
são como se fossem as instruções de
montagem para as células se regenerarem
mais rápido. Ah, eu não posso esquecer
da cúrcuma, aquele açafrão amarelinho
que a gente usa na comida. A curcumina
presente nele tem uma ação
antiinflamatória poderosa. O humo
vermelho também é bem legal. Ele forma
mucilagem que protege a calma mucosa. É
como se fosse um braço quentinho pro seu
intestino. E o famoso ômega-3, esse ele
modula a microbiota e reduz inflamação,
criando um ambiente mais favorável paraa
integridade da barreira. Agora, a grande
pergunta, qual é o melhor de todos?
Olha, não existe uma resposta única,
viu? É como perguntar qual que é a
melhor ferramenta numa caixa de
ferramentas. Depende do que você precisa
consertar. Mas se eu tivesse que
destacar os campeões, eu diria que a
glutamina e butirato são os que tm mais
evidências científicas robustas. Eles
são tipo o Batman e Robin da reparação
intestinal. O mais bacana é que você
pode combinar esses suplementos de
acordo com a sua necessidade. É uma
abordagem multibodal, nome chique para
dizer que você pode usar várias
estratégias ao mesmo tempo, tipo um time
de superheróis, cada um com seu poder
especial, trabalhando juntos para deixar
o seu intestino tinindo. Então, pessoal,
a mensagem que fica é: cuide o seu
intestino como se fosse um jardim. Você
precisa nutrir, proteger e às vezes dá
aquela forcinha extra com suplementos
certos. Lembra que o intestino é
considerado nosso segundo cérebro.
Quando ele está bem, todo o resto
funciona melhor. A saúde começa de
dentro para fora e o intestino saudável
é a base para uma vida com mais energia
e disposição. Espero que essas dicas
ajudem vocês a entender melhor como
cuidar dessa parte tão importante do
nosso corpo. E aí, qual desses
suplementos você já conheciam? Conta
para mim nos comentários. Até a próxima,
pessoal. Compartilhe os vídeos, faça
bem. A vida de alguém pode mudar também.
no canal do lendo. Trá se envolva.